oh hello Bobby bro you need to just
chill out for a sec all right you a
little too excited I'm excited apoyo
date tonight okay you've been single for
too long even though I didn't play with
Barbie I always had a crush on typically
it was just naked Barbie being rescued
by GI Joe I was an awkward kid we
couldn't even talk to girls in school
let alone dolls
Ken have we met Ken before maybe just
give him one shot okay we'll hang out
with them and we'll see where it goes
okay I'm a big fan of the classics
we're gonna go with the little black
dress it's harder than dressing my
four-year-old daughter do we only have
one option on shoes these do not go
accessorize people remember accessories
are important okay just just zip me up
don't get frisky all right just what do
you do I have never seen a Barbie look
that good that's actually kind of an A+
first date outfit Barbie's going with a
classic look she wants to look versatile
yes yet fashionable oh my god oh my god
Ken thank you so much for meeting me
tonight am I supposed to be Ken for
right now I'd appreciate if you to speak
in for a little bit maybe we could talk
about that more over dinner
you know who's driving hey babe I feel
absolutely silly right now ready pedal
to the metal
ken took Barbie on a date to her house
that's a Power Move you got it in the
Karma's like Barney we're going out to
your house you're gonna notice the
Italian marble very nice that didn't
come cheap but then again I'm not a
cheap girl mommy what are you doing in
there not pooping
why is the coolest thing I've ever done
with a toy oh wait
ken we're here in my bedroom right now
yes okay but guess what
before anything would happen here in
this bedroom I need to know that you're
thinking about marriage I had fun
exploring this dream house there's a lot
to find my sister had her Barbies I
wouldn't play with them but now I wish I
kind of brought them into my world I do
kind of wish I did play with Barbies you
see Barbie and you expect her to be like
one way but when you get the toys you
actually play with them it's whatever
you want it to be Oh
oh my gosh can I dance better than Drake
though and that hotline bling zhan doing
right now I think I'm more concerned
with the song called hotline Ken